♪ ♪
>> Tucker: NOW IT'S TIME FOR
FINAL EXAM WHEN THE YAPPING
STOPS IN THE TESTING BEGINS
WHERE THE WEEK IS -- OUR TWO
CONTESTANTS, WE FIND OUT WHO HAS
BEEN PAYING CLOSER ATTENTION TO
THE NEWS THIS WEEK.
KATIE IS THE RETURNING CHAMPION.
GAIA, YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
BEFORE.
YOU'VE GOT NERVES OF STEEL.
YOU KNOW THE RULES, BUT FOR OUR
VIEWERS WHO MAY NOT REMEMBER,
HAND ON BUZZERS, I ASKED MY
QUESTIONS, FIRST ONE WHO BUZZES
IN JUST TO ANSWER, YOU WAIT
UNTIL I FINISH ASKING.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH ONE
POINT.
AND CORRECT IT ATTRACTS A POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
QUESTION ONE, KANYE WEST WAS NOT
THE ONLY CELEBRITY CRITICIZED
THIS WEEK FOR SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES.
WHICH COUNTRY MUSIC STAR HAD THE
TEMERITY TO SAY SHE WOULD HAVE
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP?
>> SHANIA TWAIN.
>> Tucker: WE WILL SEE.
ROTATE PLEASE.
♪ ♪
>> SHANIA TWAIN GETTING SLAMMED
BY HER FANS FOR SAYING SHE WOULD
HAVE VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE SINGER WHO IS FROM CANADA
TELLING GUARDIAN SHE IS NOW
APOLOGIZING ON TWITTER SAYING
SHE REGRETS ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
>> I LIKE SOME OF HER MUSIC.
SHE WAS HONEST AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Tucker: QUESTION TWO, THE
PRESIDENT OF FRANCE VISITED, BUT
IT WAS A PIECE OF THE FIRST OF
THESE WORDS CREATED A HUGE
DISTRACTION IN THE MEDIA AND
ONLINE.
WHICH ITEM OF CLOTHING FOR
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT?
KATIE?
>> HER HAT.
HER BIG WHITE HAT.
>> Tucker: LET'S SEE IF THE
TAPE VERIFIES HER CLAIM.
>> OBVIOUSLY LOTS OF PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT MELANIA TRUMP'S
HAT.
>> I'M OUTING ERIC.
THE HAT.
IF YOU LIKE THE HAT -- WE WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT THE HAT.
SPEAK OUT WHEN YOU COMMIT TO A
HAT LIKE THAT, YOU HAVE TO WEAR
IT FOR THE REST OF THE DAY.
>> Tucker: WE WILL GO WITH HAT
HAT.
>> I'M SORRY I'M IGNORANT.
>> Tucker: NO, YOU'RE
AMERICAN.
NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR BEING AN
WHICH LAWMAKER WAS PROBABLY
PRESENTED A NEW JOB'S PLAN WHICH
WOULD GUARANTEE $15 AN HOUR
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT JOB TO
WHOEVER WANTS ONE?
>> BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Tucker: INDEPENDENT
SOCIALIST OF VERMONT.
AS OF THE CORRECT ANSWER?
>> BERNIE SANDERS REPORTEDLY
READY TO ROLL OUT A NEW
GUARANTEE FOR EVERY AMERICAN TO
GET A JOB.
>> $15 AN HOUR WITH BENEFITS.
NOT ONLY IS IT ECONOMIC
NONSENSE, IT'S ALSO GROSSLY
IMMORAL.
>> Tucker: HERE'S A QUICK
BONUS FOLLOW-UP.
IF ALL 320 MILLION AMERICANS
WORKED THERE, WOULD IT BE A
BETTER AGENCY?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE RIGHT.
QUESTION FOUR, A WOMAN WHO WAS
JUST FINED $500 BY OFFICIALS FOR
BRINGING WHAT OFTEN AIRPLANE?
WAS IT A FILTHY AIRPLANE
BLANKET, WAS IT AN APPLE, OR A
CUBAN CIGAR?
>> APPLE.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
OKAY, LET'S SEE THE TAPE.
>> U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
CONTROL TAKE A BITE OUT OF A
PASSENGER'S WALLET, FINDING HER
$500 FOR BRINGING AN APPLE OUT
OF CUSTOMS.
>> THE APPLE WAS FROM DELTA.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF THE STORY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS WHERE WE
FIND OURSELVES WITH HIGH-LEVEL
PLAYERS WHEN IT'S REALLY A
VARSITY MATCH.
IT'S 2-2, SUDDEN DEATH, QUESTION
FIVE WILL DETERMINE THE WINNER.
ARE YOU READY?
KATIE, YOU SEEM VERY CALM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE IS
CELEBRATING HIS WIFE'S BIRTHDAY
TODAY PIT HE GOT HER SOMETHING
TO MARK THE OCCASION.
WAS IT A BEAUTIFUL CARD, A
TREMENDOUS WRISTWATCH, OR SOME
KILLER HEELS?
>> THE GREATEST CARD.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEMS --
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE STICKING
WITH?
ROTATE PLEASE.
>> VERY, VERY SPECIAL DAY
BECAUSE A SMILE ON HIS BIRTHDAY.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TELL US WHAT
YOU GOT HER?
>> I DIDN'T GET HER SO MUCH, I
GOT HER A BEAUTIFUL CARD.
I'M VERY BUSY.
I GOT HER A BEAUTIFUL CARD.
>> Tucker: OUR JUDGES ARE
SAYING THAT IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
KATIE, I'M NOT SAYING I WAS
SECRETLY ROOTING FOR YOU, THOUGH
I WAS.
WE DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE -- I'M
TAKING MY PENS OUT OF THE SMOKE
AND GIVE IT TO GUY BENSON.
HERE IS THE VICTORY MUG.
>> A CONFUSED LOOK.